hi everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my video for the New Avengers endgame
post-credit scene deleted scenes and the
special Stan Lee cameo scene they tacked
all this extra footage onto the end of
Avengers and game screenings all over
the world to entice people to come back
to the theater so that they could beat
avatars box office they were within
about 40 million dollars at the
beginning of the weekend but the actual
scenes in the re-release will be rolling
out all over the world some places won't
get it till later this year the scenes
started with a Stan Lee special cameo
scene which I'll explain in a second
then we got the special Hulk scene then
they did a special spider-man far from
home post credits scene video that I'll
do a separate video for - later this
weekend if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a new round of that
imax ticket giveaway - all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Marvel post-credit scene
on the video so the post credits scenes
start with a very special Stan Lee
tribute it's actually something that's
gonna be on the blu-ray in a much longer
form because the actual post credits
scenes from Avengers endgame really only
amounted to about 7 extra minutes of
footage the full version of the Stan Lee
cameo scene will wind up being I think
it's a little over 6 minutes so this is
just a very cut-down version of that but
it contained brand new footage that
we've never seen before of them filming
his cameos all of his cameos for the
most part going back all the way to the
first Iron Man film all the way up to
what would be his final cameo and
Avengers end game during the 1970s ways
that make love not war as he screams by
that shield base when they were going to
get the tesseract made a look very much
like a 1970s version of himself no
special makeup required they'd have to
use any special effects to dhm the way
that they did the other actors just put
a wig on him and made his mustache look
a little bit bigger and that was about
all it took he talks about how wonderful
things are how he never expected the
Marvel Cinematic Universe to turn out so
well how we just wanted to inspire the
world it was a wonderful scene I can't
wait to see the full version of it when
the blu-ray drops later this summer
basically to me a hero has to be
somebody who will sacrifice or will take
great chances to help others but still
have human traits still not be perfect
when they become perfect they become
dull after the Stan Lee cameo scene
plays there's a prompt from one of the
directors Anthony Russo who says if you
can believe it
the movie actually used to be longer
it's crazy but there were a couple
scenes that just did not make the film
even though we filmed them so then plays
the Special Hulk diehard scene that they
cut out of the movie so the scene begins
on a burning building in downtown
Atlanta because they filmed the movie in
Atlanta so the scene itself within the
context of the movie is taking place in
downtown Atlanta so you start on the
burning building a firefighter runs up
to the fire chief who's wearing it
Atlanta firefighters jacket because it's
in Atlanta
he says they managed to save most of the
people from a really bad high-rise fire
but they still have people trapped on
the 40th floor
the fire chief turns around to reveal
that it's the very memorable Reginald
veljohnson from diehard family matters
and even from the original Ghostbusters
movie he says where those damn choppers
very diehard s Klein if you remember
they went on to reference diehard later
in the movie so this would have been a
setup for that when ant-man is talking
about a movie that does not involve time
travel they're just rattling off all
those pop-culture references of movies
that have time-travel in them
Ghostbusters sidenote - you may have
seen it that ant-man was also just cast
in the brand-new Ghostbusters film I
love it I'm a fan when I heard the jason
reitman was going to be doing a new
version in the fall and my agents called
him and said hey Jason we hear there's a
part of the young semi young strapping
man that needs to be cast who you gonna
call when I heard
they were going to call me well you can
imagine
I nearly slimed myself after he screams
about the choppers the camera goes back
to that top floor of the burning
building the CG isn't quite finished yet
because they cut the scene out while
they were in post-production Avengers
music kicks in as Hulk starts busting
through the walls just like he did
during the first Avengers movie when he
was trying to chase Black Widow just
ripping through the bulkheads but this
time it's professor Hulk he's smart and
he's there to save all those people that
are trapped at the top as the
firefighter and the fire chief look up
at the building the camera cuts back to
the outside you see Hulk scooped up all
the people in a giant satellite dish
that he's ripped off the roof and then
start jumping from rooftop to lower
rooftop till it lands on the ground
it says ding ding ground floor everybody
out in what would have been a setup for
the Hulk hating stairs joke later in the
movie when all the Avengers in the
Avengers Tower 2012 make him take the
stairs what are you trying to do buddy
and then he just screams his way down
the stairs too many stairs the die-hard
scene continues as he goes to talk to
Reginald veljohnson 'he's fire chief
saying cheap so that bars burn at about
900 Kelvin between you and me Halon
bombs above and below the burn zone
Halon bombs are just a special device
that firefighters use to extinguish
large building fires they're pretty
hardcore
but it's meant to be an example of smart
Hulk solving his problems rather than
just smashing them away with Reginald
veljohnson just staring a professor Hulk
like he can't believe what's going on he
just brushes right past him like this is
what we need to do but then he gets a
phone call on a giant iPad looking phone
that I guess he needs to use because his
Hulk hands are so big he answers the
phone saying go for Hulk so he's
referring to himself as Hulk now and not
as Bruce Banner then says Steve who
because I guess it's not Captain America
calling him and the person who called
him from the Avengers didn't say which
Steve they wanted to meet but they were
calling him to meet them at the diner
and that's where you get the actual
diner scene with him eating all that
food and explaining how he became
professor Hulk and what's going on now
18 months in the gamma lab I put the
brains and the Brawn together and now
they give me
best of both worlds there were two big
reasons for this diehard scene in
Atlanta and all the dialog one I think
to explain why the Hulk is so popular
now like all the little kids in the
diner ask him for selfies so we've just
gotten around that Hulk is going all
over the United States helping people do
things like this so people love the Hulk
now he's so helpful and awesome to
explain a little bit about how Professor
Hulk works and how he's so cognitive and
he's able to talk to people the chatty
version of the Hulk and to to set up the
Iron Man Infinity Gauntlet scene where
Hulk feels like he's the only one who
could wield that snapping everyone back
because Thor's not doing so hot and they
lost Scarlet Witch when she got snapped
so they're just not that many people
around that could actually survive in
Infinity Gauntlet snap but the writers
talked a little bit about why they wrote
that scene and why they took it out of
the movie saying you never know what's
actually going to make it out in the
world we did a scene illustrating it
more actively what the Hulk had been up
to in terms of being a hero as opposed
to just starting it in the diner and
explaining things but it didn't give you
anything that you didn't already get
from just sitting in the diner eating
pancakes and it came off more as noise
than his content I would have loved to
see that die hard Reginald veljohnson
cameo so I don't really think of this
seen as being noise but they're just
trying to explain that you get all the
info that you need about Professor Hulk
from the diner scene which is why they
didn't have a whole big sequence in the
movie of him becoming professor Hulk
going from being Banner and Hulk to
being the fused professor Hulk he just
explains that it took 18 months in a
gamma lab and he spliced the DNA he
figured it out so isn't much of a
bummers that is for big Hulk fans that's
why they didn't put that in the movie
maybe we'll get a version of that and
one of the Avengers spin-off TV shows I
know there's some weird issues with the
Hulk rights like though never gonna be
able to do a hulk movie until Universal
finally gives them the rights to
distribute it I'll probably eventually
do a separate video about what's going
on with the rights issues for characters
that Marvel doesn't totally have a
hundred percent of the rights to like
Hulk and she-hulk
there's a certain amount of things that
they can do with those characters and
that they can't that's why you only see
Hulk in other people's movies you don't
see hoaxes solo films I want to just
make one thing perfectly clear today a
standalone Hulk movie will never happen
because Universal has the rights to
stand alone Hulk movie and for some
reason they don't know how to play well
with Marvel and and they don't want to
make money and with you as the new Hulk
it would be terrible know that these
corporations would work it out if they
thought they'd make enough money so
think about who's playing let's but I
mean I figure I got like two or three
more years left before they I'm too old
to play the whole year we talked about
it but I I just I don't see it in the
cards these feet in the car Rosencrantz
and Guildenstern after this scene they
played that special Spider Man far from
home post-credit scene which I'll do a
separate video for in the next day but
for about the next week or so you can go
to the theater and see this but what you
have to do is is it doesn't play before
the credits you actually had to sit
through every single one of the credits
there's like a couple seconds of black
after the credits finish where you would
see a normal post credits scene then
after a few beats this New Avengers
endgame post credits scene content
starts rolling I think it was a digital
download that they sent to all the
theaters and I don't think that they're
going to be posting any of it online but
a lot of it will wind up on the blu-ray
release so I believe the Hulk scene I
know the Stan Lee cameo scene in the
spider-man far from home stuff is really
part of the movie so that's gonna be
separate spider-man far from home
blu-ray content even though the movie
was three hours long let me know in the
comments would you have rather seen a
special sequence of the hook becoming
professor hook before you got that diner
scene where he's talking to the other
Avengers whole bunch of spider-man
videos coming up this week be sure to go
see the movie when you have the
opportunity it's starting to roll out
worldwide it should be everywhere by
Monday and Tuesday so as long as you
have alerts enable for my channel you'll
see all the videos when I post them
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video
Filip Janek please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details click here to learn about a
whole bunch of deleted scenes from
spider-man
bar from home from the trailers some
cameos that did not make it into the
actual movie some of them are actually
pretty cool and click here for that
taskmaster vs. black widow teaser from
the avengers endgame prequel movie thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight